[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans Parlement
hebbdo l'actualité parlementaire
décryptée par un invité politique et
pour la dernière pour la dernière
émission de l'année 2023 on accueille
Yann brossa bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur communiste de Paris
porte-parole du Parti communiste
français et co-président du groupe
communiste au Conseil de Paris c'est le
texte le plus attendu de cette fin
d'année l'Assemblée nationale entame ce
lundi l'examen du projet de loi
immigration les députés ont sensiblement
réécrit la version qui avait été voté et
durci par les
sénateurs à la veille de ce débat la
droite fait monter la pression sur le
gouvernement la majorité sénatoriale a
déposé une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour demander un
référendum sur l'immigration et on
parlera du projet de loi de finances
2024 qui est en discussion au Sénat les
sénateurs ont notamment rejeter le
budget du logement ils estiment que le
gouvernement ne répond pas assez à la
crise actuelle du logement l'examen du
projet de loi immigration commence ce
lundi à l'Assemblée nationale en séance
publique de semaines de débat qui
s'annoncent tendu le texte a déjà été
remagné par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée els
mandingava en commission les députés ont
largement validé la nouvelle version du
projet de loi sur l'ensemble de la loi
pour contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration qui vote pour 35 voix pour
il y a donc 16 voix contre la loi est
adoptée par la commission les députés
ont rétabli l'aide médicale d'État que
les sénateurs de droite avaient limité à
une aide médicale d'urgence la
commission des lois a également supprimé
le délit de séjour irrégulier concernant
le titre de séjour métier en tension un
amendement de compromis du rapporteur
Florent bouier a été adopté le préfet
pourra s'opposer à sa délivr en cas de
menace à l'ordre public de non respect
des valeurs de la République ou encore
de polygamie je pense que nous
atteignons là une disposition conforme à
la cible qui était la
nôtre un dispositif de régularisation
resserré qui correspond à des besoins
économiques qui permettent aussi de
tirer de l'illégalité et parfois de
conditions inacceptables de maltraitance
un certain nombre de ressortissant en
situation irrégulière l'amendement des
sénateurs communistes pour donner un
titre de jour aux étrangers qui
dénonceraient un marchand de sommeil a
été conservé et étendu aux victimes de
proxenet l'interdiction de placement en
centre de rétention administrative
concernera les mineurs de moins de 18
ans et non plus 16 ans comme dans la
version sénatoriale coup d'envoie des
débats dans l'hémicycle lundi à
16h y B on va parler du fond du test
mais avant cela cette question les
députés écologistes vont déposer lundi
une motion de rejet préalable du projet
de loi immigration ça veut dire que si
cette motion est adoptée et bien le
texte est rejeté en séance publique il
n'y a plus de débat est-ce que vous vous
souhaitez que cette motion de rejet
aboutisse ou vous souhaitez au contraire
que le débat ait lieu sur l'immigration
je je souhaite effectivement que cette
motion soit adopté et qu'on puisse enfin
parler des vrais problèmes des Français
je suis quand même frappé par le fait
que on parle aujourd'hui matin midi et
soir d'immigration d'immigration
d'immigration on ne parle jamais des
enjeux du pouvoir d'achat jamais d'un
niveau des prix jamais des salaires et
donc si on écoute la macronie la droite
et l'extrême droite on a un espace
politique qui est saturé par les
question d'immigration donc
effectivement tout ce qui nous permettra
de revenir au vrais problèm des Français
de ne pas passer 3 semaines sur ce texte
est bon à prendre alors le projet de loi
a été déjà durci par la majorité de
droite sénatoriale et le texte a été
remanié on l'a vu par les députés en
commission des lois par exemple un
travailleur sans papier dans un secteur
en tension pourra être régularisé il y a
certaines euh exceptions vous êtes
satisfait par le rééquilibrage sur cette
mesure qui a été fait par les députés
disons en tout cas que le texte tel
qu'il sortait du Sénat était euh
ressemblait comme de gouttes d'eau à un
traac du Front national des années 80
donc les députés en commission des lois
ont fait leur travail et ont un peu
rééquilibré ce texte même si l'équilibre
global à mes yeux reste très mauvais en
tout cas pour ce qui concerne la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier pour ce qui nous concerne nous
les communistes nous y sommes favorables
quand quelqu'un travaille en France
quand quelqu'un paye des impôts paye des
cotisations sociales parce que c'est de
ça qu'on parle oui il doit avoir la
possibilité d'avoir des papiers et on ne
peut pas avoir des secteur entier de
notre économie qui repose sur des gens
qui n'ont pas de papier c'est notamment
le cas dans l'hôtellerie et dans la
restauration nous nous sommes favorables
à la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papier le fait de
travailler parfois depuis des années moi
j'en ai rencontré qui travaillent en
France depuis 10 ans doit donner lieu à
des papiers pour que ces personnes
puissent sortir de la clandestinité et
avoir les mêmes droits que n'importe
quel travailleur et qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ce ce qui dit qu'il y a des
risques de de faire une de créer un
appel d'air pour de de nouveaux
travailleurs sans papier qui viendrai
qu'est-ce que vous répondez les
personnes qui disent cela n'ont rien
compris on parle de travailleurs qui
sont déjà là j'ai rencontré encore
l'autre jour à à une mobilisation de de
travailleurs
d'uberit ils sont sans papiers ils
travaillent pour 30 € par jour 30 € par
jour et ils font 7 he par jour donc
c'est de l'exploitation c'est c'est de
l'exploitation et cette exploitation
elle est liée au fait qu'ils n'ont pas
de papier c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas
de papier qu'on peut les traiter comme
ça et donc les sortir de la
clandestinité leur permet leur permettre
pardon d'accéder à n'importe au même
droit que n'importe quel travailleur
c'est bon à la fois pour eux mais c'est
bon pour le monde du travail dans son
ensemble parce que ça nous permet de
sortir d'une logique de dumping qui tire
tout le monde vers le bas donc je pense
que ce serait effectivement nécessaire
et d'ailleurs je sais que les députés
communistes vont travailler pour étendre
cet article de telle sorte qu'il puisse
concerner tous les travailleurs sans
papier y compris d'ailleurs les salar
qui comme les les uberit par exemple
non'ont pas un statut de salarié mais un
statut d'auto-entrepreneur il brossa une
question sur l'aide médicale d'État en
commission les députés ont rétabli
l'aide médicale d'État qui avait été
restreinte dans son panier de soins par
la majorité de droite du Sénat et
d'ailleurs cette semaine un rapport
commandé par le gouvernement sur l'aide
médicale d'État a été rendu publique ses
auteurs claudévin et Patrick stéphanini
reconnaissent que cette aide est utile
nécessaire mais il prévoit quand même
des adaptations certains coup draabau
est-ce que pour vous il faut réformer
cette aide médicale d'État ou la garder
tel qu'elle il faut la préserver et je
je suis très heureux de voir que après
les débats assez nousé à bond d'ailleurs
que nous avons eu au Sénat sur le sujet
on remette un peu de de raison dans ce
débat d'abord de quoi on parle on parle
de gens qui ont besoin d'être soignés et
c'est un principe de base quand des gens
sont malades on leur permet d'accéder
aux soins et l'idée même qu'on puisse
remettre en cause ce principe
fondamental et pour moi profondément
profondément scandaleuse et donc je je
note d'ailleurs que ce rapport qui a été
rédigé y compris par Patrick Stéphan
Claudé vin bien sûr mais Patrick
stéphanini aussi qui n'est pas tout à
fait un dangereux gauchiste puisque de
mémoire il était directeur de campagne
de Valérie pcrè note qu'on a besoin de
l'aide médicale d'État il fait un
certain nombre de suggestions pour
l'aménager mais il dit il faut préserver
l'aide médicale d'État au passage c'est
quand même une claque monumentale pour
ceux qui à droite du côté des LR ont
voulu purement et simplement supprimer
laame puisque c'est l'un des leurs qui
leur dit que ce serait une une absurdité
alors les députés en commission des lois
ont conservé certaines mesures mure voté
au Sénat notamment celle qui facilite
les expulsions des étrangers délinquants
ou criminels est-ce que vous êtes opposé
à ces expulsions de criminels
délinquants quand on est en présence de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de papier
clandestin qui est dangereux dont les
les services de renseignement nous
disent qu'il est dangereux je ne suis
pas choqué qu'on l'éloigne du territoire
français non donc c'est une ligne de
fracture au sein de la gauche par
exemple la France insmise elle dit que
elle est vraiment contre cette double
peine ce n'est pas une double peine en
l'occurrence puisque ce sont des
personnes qui sont sans papier qui sont
en situation de clandestinité dès lors
qu'elles le sont et qu'en plus de ça on
a tous les éléments qui nous indiquent
qu'elles sont dangereuses je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'elles reste sur le
territoire français je je pense quand
même que tout le monde devrait pouvoir
être d'accord làdesus vous approuvez ces
dispositions qui ont été conservées par
les déput de toute façon aujourd'hui une
personne qui est en situation
irrégulière on a la possibilité de
l'expulser à forceori si elle est
considérée comme dangereuse il y a pas
besoin il y a pas besoin en l'occurrence
de changer la loi pour procéder à
l'expulion ça concerne aussi les
étrangers réguliers qui ont été
condamnés pour des crimes pour des
délits et parfois on n'arrive pas à les
expulser alors pour ce qui concerne une
personne qui est en situation régulière
je suis favorable à ce qu'elle soit
sanctionné comme n'importe quelle
personne qui est sur le territoire
français de manière régulière donc donc
la prison alors on a bien compris les
députés ont par ailleurs conservé
l'amendement des sénateurs communistes
le vôtre qui donne un un titre de séjour
aux étrangers qui dénonceraient un
marchand de sommeil ils ont même étendu
cette disposition aux victimes de
proxénet est-ce que vous pensez que la
mesure sera conservée et qu'il faut la
conserver dans le projet de loi je je je
le souhaite d'ailleurs c'est la seule
avancée qui a été obtenue par déjà
hisire pour vous oui c'est c'est la
seule avancée qui a été obtenue par la
gauche au Sénat et je suis très heureux
que avec mon groupe nous l'ayons porté
quelle est l'idée l'idée c'est que vous
avez aujourd'hui des personnes qui sont
victimes de marchands de sommeil et je
l'ai vu dans le cadre de l'exercice de
mon mandat d'adjoint au maire Paris
elles sont victimes de marchands de
sommeil 40 % des victimes de marchands
de sommeil n'ont pas de papier et donc
elles sont victimes de cette de cette
exploitation elles n'osent pas porter
plainte précisément parce qu'elles n'ont
pas de papier elles ont peur en allant
au commissariat de subir une cttf et
donc ce que nous disons nous c'est il
faut les protéger il faut leur permettre
d'accéder à un titre de séjour
provisoire ce qui permettra d'ailleurs
de les reloger parce que le problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
exproprie des immeubles qui sont
propriétés de marchands de sommeil et on
n'a pas la possibilité de reloger les
habitants parce que si vous n'avez pas
de papier vous pouvez même pas déposer
une demande de logement donc ça
permettra à la fois de mieux repérer les
situations de marchand de sommeil de les
condamner et puis de permettre à ces
personnes d'être relogé et d'avoir une
vie digne après avoir subi des choses
souvent atroces alors Yan brossa on
continue à parler d'immigration puisque
les parlementaires les républicains
veulent modifier notre Constitution pour
mieux maîtriser notre politique
migratoire et soumettre le sujet à
référendum au français une proposition
loi constitutionnelle a été défendue
hier sans succès par les députés les
républicains et elle sera débattue la
semaine prochaine au Sénat et vous allez
voir les sénateurs centristes ne sont
pas d'accord avec leurs collègues de la
majorité au Sénat sénateurs les
républicains Flora sauvage coup dur pour
les LR au Sénat mercredi en commission
lors de l'examen de leur proposition de
loi constitutionnelle sur l'immigration
leurs alliés centristes ont rejeté deux
articles phares ce texte est
emblématique pour la droite sénatoriale
qui l'ériige comme une réponse à
l'immigration massive il faut permettre
aux Français de se déterminer pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que il
y a pas un phénomène qui est autant
bouleversé depuis un demi-sècle la
société française sans que les Français
n'ai jamais été consultés puis surtout
les résultats d'un référendum s'imposent
au Conseil constitutionnelle la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle des
sénateurs LR prévoyait d'élargir à la
question migratoire les conditions du
recours au référendum en modifiant
l'article 11 de la Constitution pour les
centristes c'était une ligne rougeir
faire ça c'est dangereux maintenant
parce que ça ouvrirait la possibilité
d'un référendum sur une question comme
l'immigration mais ce sera encore plus
dangereux demain si un jour par exemple
politique fiction mais si Madame Le Pen
arrivit au pouvoir et qu'on lui donne
les moyens de faire un tel référendum
alors à ce moment là on pourra avoir de
grandes difficultés autre proposition
qui s'est heurtée à l'opposition des
sénateurs centristes que des lois
organiques puissent déroger aux accords
internationaux ou au droits européens si
les règles européennes contreviennent à
l'identité constitutionnelle de la
France le droit de l'Union européenne
est un droit qui s'impose au droit
national c'est un droit qui s'impose aux
parlementaires dans ce domaine là mais
aussi dans d'autres domaines et donc
nous ne voulons pas réinverser la
hiérarchie des normes du côté de
l'exécutif s'il n'était pas hostile à
l'idée d'élargir la possibilité de tenir
des référendum sur des sujets sociétaux
tels que l'immigration Emmanuel Macron y
a finalement renoncé faute de consensus
selon le ministre de l'Intérieur géralde
daranin la proposition de loi du groupe
LR s'apparente à un double frxit
européen et constitutionnel Yann brossa
avant de parler du fond de cette réforme
constitutionnelle on va parler euh de
l'enjeu politique est-ce que vous pensez
que les sénateurs les républicains qui
sont quand même le premier groupe
politique au Sénat vont être en minorité
sur leur texte en tout cas ça commence
déjà à ressembler à un fiasco puisque y
compris en commission des lois au Sénat
j'y siège j'y étais ils ont été battus
sur les deux principaux articles de leur
de de leur proposition de loi
constitutionnelle à la fois sur la
question du R référendum et sur la
question de la dérogation au droit
européens or c'était quand même
là-dessus que cette proposition reposait
pour l'essentiel notamment parce que et
la droite pardon et les centristes et la
gauche ont rejeté ont rejeté ces deux
dispositions donc oui pour l'instant
c'est un fiasco et tant mieux donc il va
y avoir une sorte de nouvelle alliance
centre et gauche au Sénat pour combattre
ce texte vous allez peut-être vous allez
peut-être vite en besogne disons qu'il y
a encore au Sénat des gens qui gardent
quelques réflexes et qui en l'occurrence
quand des propositions ahurissantes
comme cell-là leur sont soumises font
valoir ces ces réflexes républicains qui
qui sont quand même un peu nécessaires
si on a envie que nos institutions
fonctionnent alors sur le fond est-ce
que c'est une bonne idée oui ou non donc
de réviser notre constitution de vouloir
la réviser pour mieux maîtriser notre
politique migratoire d'abord vous voyez
ce que je vous disais ces gens saturent
l'espace politique avec les questions
d'immigration tout le temps c'est on
vient de finir
l'examen bien sûr on vient de finir
l'examen du projet de loi immigration au
Sénat qu'on a maintenant dans le cadre
de la niche DLR un débat sur la réforme
de la Constitution et alors la réforme
de la Constitution uniquement autour de
de de l'enjeu de vous dites que ça se
termine en fiasco il ça se termin en
fiasco parce que à force de jouer avec
le feu on finit par se cramé c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
produire et je n'en suis pas insatisfait
parce que je pense effectivement que ça
peut leur servir de leçon j'espère qu'un
jour quand même au Parlement on pourra
débattre des vrais problèmes des gens
les salaires le travail tout ce qui fait
que aujourd' beaucoup de gens qu'ils
auront pas les moyens de payer des
cadeaux de Noël pour leurs enfants à la
constitution pas besoin de toucher à la
constitution non mais vous vous rendez
compte ils disent qu'il faut déroger aux
règles européennes les mêmes d'ailleurs
pas Bruno rotaillo mais beaucoup
d'autres alr qui ont voté tous les
traités européens tous les traités
européens sans exception qui compris
sont passés par le traité de Lisbonne
pour passer par-dessus le vote des
Français en 2005 nous disent maintenant
on va déroger au traité européen
uniquement sur la question de
l'immigration enfin en réalité pas sur
la question de l'immigration sur la
question des droits de l'homme parce que
ce sont quand même des traités qui
concernent les droits de l'homme
c'est-à-dire que la France va ressembler
à la Pologne et à la Hongrie excusez-moi
de vous le dire mon modèle pour la
France quand même un grand pays c'est ni
la Pologne ni la Hongrie et et et la
France pays des droits de l'homme se
doit d'avoir encore quelques grands
principes qu'on respecte et donc je
j'espère que ce fiasco va servir de
leçon au Républicain sur le référendum
quand même pourquoi ne pas demander
l'avis des français sur ce sujet
migratoire et qu'est-ce qu'on va
demander aux Français sur l'immigration
qu'est-ce qu'on va leur demander quelle
sera la question qu'on leur pose
bah par exemple sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier ça peut
être une question mais mais vous vous
rendez compte que on a eu des millions
de Français qui ont manifester pour
obtenir un référendum sur sur les
retraites on leur a dénié le droit de se
prononcer sur une réforme comme celle-là
et maintenant on va réformer notre
Constitution pour éventuellement demain
leur poser une question sur
l'immigration qu'on commence par poser
aux Français les questions qu'ils
attendent en l'occurrence ils
attendaient d'être interrogés sur la
question des retraites si si certains
cherchent d'autres idées une autre idée
qu'on interroge les Français par
référendum c'est une proposition que
nous faisons avec Fabien Roussel sur
l'indexation des salaires sur les prix
ça se pratique en Belgique quand les
prix augmentent les salaires augmentent
d'autant pour éviter que nos revenus
soient dévorés par l'inflation ben qu'on
fasse ça et ça permettra de répondre
bien davantage aux préoccupations des
Français alors ce jeudi à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés LR ont déposé un
un tas de textes au titre de leur
journée d'initiativ parlementaires et il
y avait notamment cette proposition de
résolution qui appelle le gouvernement a
dénoncé l'accord franco-algérien de 1968
cet accord qui facilite l'arrivée de
ressortissants algériens et de leur
famille sur le territoire ça a été
rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale ce
jeudi vous vous en félicitez oui je m'en
félicite je je je je note que c'est
quand même 3è texte 3è texte qui
concerne les les les les questions
d'immigration don dont notre Parlement
est saisi ouii je me je me félicite que
ce texte étit il faut pas toucher à cet
accord le gouvernement ve les renégoci
je je je quel est le sujet en fait on
considère qu'il y a trop d'Algériens en
France qu quel est le quel moi je
partage pas cette vision des choses je
suis dans un arrondissement à Paris le
18e j'en suis élu qui a notamment été un
lieu où se sont installés beaucoup
d'Algériens pas de problème avec les
Algériens c'est quoi le sujet pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a besoin en permanence de
de de réveiller de vieilles querelles je
jeis frappé par par le fait que ces gens
sont quand même obsédés ont des
obsessions permanentes sur un certain
nombre de sujets que je ne partage pas
et pourtant Elizabeth borne envisage une
renégociation de ce traité bilatéral
franco-algérien ne vous a pas échappé
que je ne suis pas le porte-parole
d'éisabeth borne et donc je ne souhaite
pas qu'on qu' qu' qu'on touche à ce
sujet mais de manière générale je ne
partage pas l'idée selon laquelle
l'immigration serait une espèce de
menace dont il faudrait se prémunir
quand il y a des gens dangereux une fois
de plus il faut il faut les écarter mais
la grande masse des étrangers qui vivent
sur le territoire français travaillent
veulent vivre dignement avec leur
famille et méritent d'être respter et on
n pas besoin d'agiter ce sujet en
permanence comme le font certains
dernière question sur les propositions
des députés les républicains ce jeudi à
l'Assemblée Eric Coti a proposé
d'instaurer une rétention de sûreté pour
les personnes condamnées pour terrorisme
et qui sont sortis de prison et qui
seraiit jugé encore dangereuse ce qui
était le cas du tueur de l'attentat de
la Tour Effel le weekend dernier cette
rétention de sûreté ça pourrait
permettre d'éviter de nouveaux av
attentats quand quand quelqu'un a été
condamné on a possibilité de de de la
signer à résidence par exemple ill mais
dans ce caslà il faut des peines de
prison plus lourdes c'est ça le sujet et
en l'occurrence on aurait pu dans dans
ce cas-là avoir une peine de prison plus
lourde on n pas besoin d'ajouter des
éléments dans notre droit comme le
propose Eric cotti dès qu'un événement
le droit actuel suffit le droit le droit
actuel suffit à condition de de
l'appliquer et par ailleurs on n'est pas
au bout de l'enquête y a quand même
aussi la question de la psychiatrie qui
est posée psychiatrie qui est quand même
est quand même dans notre pays dans une
situation absolument catastrophique
enfin bref il y a plusieurs sujets qui
se mêle et je pense qu'avant de proposer
des modifications législatives il faut
quand même regarder de près les
événements qui se sont déroulés alors
Yanne brossa le Sénat a continué
d'examiner cette semaine le projet loi
de finance pour 2024 et notamment les
moyens financiers donnés aux différents
ministères et bien les sénateurs ont
rejeté le budget du logement Yann brossa
vous avez été l'adjoint d'algo au
logement à la mairie de Paris vous
connaissez ces questions par cœur ce
budget du gouvernement ne répond pas
selon la majorité sénatoriale à la crise
actuel du logement écoutez Dominique
Estrosi sonne on en parle juste après
les blocages et les tensions dont nous
sommes les témoins dans le parcours
résidentiel sont de puissants vecteurs
de frustration et de ressentiment ne pas
pouvoir accéder au logement social ou ne
pas pouvoir en sortir renoncer à un
emploi ou à des études faute de logement
ne pas réaliser son rêve d'accéder à la
propriété voir d'acheter une maison avec
jardin pour sa famille comme ses parents
sont autant de faits qui aliment un
sentiment de déclassement de relégation
ou d'assignation à résidence à certains
égards la révolte des gilets jaunes les
émeutes urbaines de l'été ou encore les
réactions de plus en plus agressives
contre
Airbnb sont autant d'éruption de
violence face aux injustices dont le
logement et la cause ou le symptôme Yann
brossa vous êtes d'accord avec l'analyse
de la sénatrice est-ce que la prochaine
crise c'est celle-ci la crise autour du
logement qui risque de mener à une
explosion sociale ah je pense que je je
pense que oui parce que la situation du
logement à l'échelle nationale
aujourd'hui particulièrement en
territoire tendu et absolument
catastrophique et et le gouvernement
porte une lourde responsabilité
là-dedans vous savez quand le
gouvernement a décidé de ponctionner
dans les caisses des bailleurs HLM en
expliquant que les bailleurs HLM avaient
des finances extrêmement bonnes nous
avions alerté nous avions dit attention
vous ponctionnez des milliards d'euros
dans les caisses des bailleurs sociaux
ça va avoir deux conséquences
premièrement ils vont moins rénover leur
parc deuxièmement la construction de
logements sociaux va ralentir et quce
son erreur aujourdhui le gouvernement
est totalement responsable de la
situation actuelle vous avez aujourd'hui
une baisse par rapport au début du
premier quinquen à Macron de 20 % de la
construction de HLM on n jamais produit
depuis des dizaines d'années aussi peu
de logements sociaux dans notre pays
alors qu'on a jamais eu un besoin aussi
important de logement abordable donc oui
le gouvernement en est très largement
responsable et pourtant le gouvernement
cette année dans ce budget 2024 porte un
budget du logement en Haus d' 1,5
milliard d'euros par rapport à l'an
dernier ce n'est pas suffisant pour
cette crise c'est très très largement
insuffisant notamment parce que les
bailleurs sociaux sont aujourd'hui à sec
notamment aussi parce que les
collectivités local ont de plus en plus
de difficultés quand vous faites du
logement que ce soit d'ailleurs du
logement social ou du logement privé du
logement fam familiale vous avez
derrière besoin de financer des
équipements publics vous avez besoin de
crèche Vous avez besoin d'écoes donc on
aurait besoin par exemple c'est une
proposition que nous faisons de renouer
avec une vraie aide au Mair bâtisseur
permettre au maire de construire du
logement et les équipements publics qui
qui vont avec faciliter le travail des
maires ça c'est une une proposition que
nous faisons mais en tout cas oui je
pense que le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui très très loin du compte et
ne se rend pas bien compte des
difficultés de logement de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui alors cette
crise du logement est une crise à
multiples facteurs très complexes le
Sénat va lancer une mission
d'information sur cette crise quel doit
être l'objectif numéro 1 de cette
mission sur un sujet aussi complexe pour
moi il y a deux sujets premièrement
comment on relance la construction
comment on permet que on construise plus
de logements dans notre pays du logement
social du logement abordable de manière
générale et deuxièmement redonner envie
aux promoteurs redonner envie aux
promoteurs aux communes aussi de de
faire du logement social et puis
deuxièmement comment on régule mieux le
marché du logement parce que le constat
que je peux faire par exemple dans une
ville comme Paris c'est que on a de
moins en moins de possibilités de
construire et on a dans le même temps de
plus en plus de logements qui existent
qui sont là mais qui sont vides soit
totalement soit les tris/4 de l'année
donc comment on fait en sorte que ces
logements soient remis sur le marché ce
qui pose la question de la de la
fiscalité du logement moi je
souhaiterais qu'on puisse taxer beaucoup
plus fortement les logements vacants et
les résidences secondaires dans les
zones tendues pour que ces logements
soient remis sur le marché encadrer
aussi davantage les prix du marché de
l'immobilier oui bien bien sûr en tout
cas je je je souhaiterais par exemple
qu'on ait la possibilité d'encadrer les
prix du foncier parce que c'est le prix
du foncier bien souvent exorbitant qui a
des conséquences au final sur le prix du
logement que vous payez sur le prix de
sortie donc la possibilité d'encadrer
les prix du foncier ce serait ce serait
une avancée c'était d'ailleurs proposé
dans le cadre du CNR sur le logement
avant
l'été exactement et le gouvernement a
malheureusement balayé cette proposition
d'un rever de demain alors sur
l'hébergement d'urgence le gouvernement
bat des records de places créé avec plus
de 200000 places au total est-ce que
vous saluez l'effort fait non parce que
ça n'est pas suffisant vous avez
effectivement aujourd'hui sur le
territoire national
203000 places d'hébergement sauf que le
constat que nous faisons c'est qu'on a
encore beaucoup de gens qui dorment
dehors et qu'on en a même de plus en
plus et notamment des enfants l'UNICEF
l'a montré en 1 an on a eu plus 42 %
d'enfants qui dorment à la rue on le
voit on a 2 d's vous avez défendu un
amendement qui a été adopté sur ce sujet
effectivement nous avons fait
collectivement adopter un amendement au
projet de loi de finance au Sénat qui
permet de créer 6000 places
d'hébergement supplémentaires ce que je
souhaite c'est que le gouvernement
conserve ces 6000 places d'hébergement
supplémentaire et qu'il ne le balayent
pas d'un revers de main par un nouveau
493 quand même quand même permettre que
des enfants qui ont quelques jours
parfois quelques mois et un toit sur la
tête et ne dorment pas à la rue je pense
que ça devrait faire consensus et je
note que si on a été capable de dégager
sur ce sujet une majorité au Sénat le
gouvernement pourrait être bien inspiré
de de persister sur ce de enfin en tout
cas de nous donner raison sur ce de
conserver cette mesure dernière question
Yann brossa sur les locations de meublés
touristiques type Airbnb une proposition
de loi à l'Assemblée nationale pour
davantage les régulés a été reporté en
raison d'une obstruction des députés RN
des députés les républicains vous
connaissez ce dossier par cœur à Paris
pour vous jusqu'où il faut aller pour
réguler ces locations Airbnb d'abord
honte au députés R qui se sont conduits
comme des larbins d'une multinationale
américaine moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que dans un certain nombre de
territoires on puisse interdire ces
locations touristiques lorsqu'elles se
font au détriment du logement des
classes moyennes et ben ce sera le mot
de la fin Yann brossa merci d'avoir
étéinité de cette émission à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]